- [Narrator] You spend all
day being the perfect boss.
And the perfect mom.
And the perfect wife.
But sometimes, sometimes you
just gotta be a little bad.
- Oh shoot, guys I gotta go
finish some reports for work.
- [Narrator] You need
something sweet and salty.
Just like you.
(bag rips)
- Honey, are you
eating something?
- No, I'm doing work reports.
(food crunching)
- Mommy.
- Mommy's busy.
- [Narrator] Your
little midnight snack
is nobody's business.
Introducing new Shhhh-Nacks.
From Frito Lay.
(gentle music)
Utilizing a patented silencing
technology previously
only available to secretly
American funded death squads
in El Salvador.
New Shhhh-Nacks let you hide
the shame eating you do to
fill the void left by
such things as your
parents, your dad,
your mom, both your parents,
your bottomless sad love life,
your less than great
hair, and all magazines.
Not only are the bags
silent so are the chips.
(knocking)
- Susan, you left in the
middle of the meeting,
is everything okay?
- Yep, just silently pooping.
- [Narrator] If a chip
falls in your stomach
and there's no one there to
hear it, are you really sad?
New Shhh-nacks, when you're
trying to feed a hunger
you can't let anyone know
about because you're humiliated
by basic human desires.
From the makers of Shame
Spirals and Los Angeles.
(gentle music)